for the last week I guess or to find out
what hints I might give about the final
exam let me speak about the final exam
to start i finished composing it this
morning it will be one long essay it's a
take-home exam it will be due on the
22nd which is the normal examination day
for the course it asks a car it presents
an issue and asks you to write an essay
on it and it has some suggestive
questions that might help you in
composing the essay but they are
completely optional as is the question
of how much you may feel that you should
make reference to either lectures or the
textbook this is a course on how to
think about world history not a course
on whether or not you read the earth and
its peoples or attended or viewed the
lectures you may wish that it was the
latter but if it is the forward so I
won't say anything about the content of
it except that I've put down 2,500 words
as the length but I'm looking for which
is about eight pages something like that
in other words it's a fairly substantial
essay
today I'm going to talk about the
chapter on global maritime expansion I
think is ingeniously entitled so that by
talking about global and expansion it
allows the Mediterranean not to be
discussed because the Mediterranean was
already unknown maritime arena and
therefore the separation between what
happens with Mediterranean what happens
in in the Indian Ocean or the Atlantic
can be maintained even though
historically they were closely
interrelated I am going to talk on
Thursday about what I would have said in
the second semester if I had continued
teaching the course because I will not
be teaching it next semester I'm going
on leave and I will resume the course in
the fall under current plans for any of
you who are still around or interested
in seeing what happens next
so I want to talk about some of the
themes that I had a mind to pursue by
getting up to 1500 we have gone through
95% of the timeline of human history
that the course undertakes as say from
roughly 8000 BC to 1500 uh that is the
first half of the course the second half
is a remaining 500 years so clearly
there's a vast disproportion between the
first and the second semesters
the decision on where to split the
course was one that we deliberated over
and you could make an argument that 1500
was an imperfect choice if you were for
example focusing upon economic matters
you might choose 1600 because that is
when you have the formation of the joint
stock companies Dutch East India Company
the English East India Company that that
more than anything shaped the destinies
of the Imperial maritime powers in later
centuries if you had wanted to focus on
the odd on the Mongol impact then you
might have chosen 1400 so 1500 is kind
of in between but of course it also has
the awkwardness that it splits from
European point of view the Renaissance
from the Reformation which is different
from the old way of teaching Western Civ
where Renaissance and Reformation were
seen as as intimately related because
all of the issues that that came up in
the Renaissance in terms of the revival
of thinking from greco-roman antiquity
and the coming end of new tendencies
from the Muslim world tended to
contribute to challenging the supremacy
of of the church and that supremacy of
course is what becomes formally
challenged with Martin Luther early in
the 1500s so we get a somewhat awkward
split there
this particular chapter does an
interesting job of trying to finesse the
the timeline it is in a part of the book
that ends in 1500 as I say and that is
supposed to be the end of the first
semester for a course that is vitam two
semesters but this chapter goes to 1550
none of the other chapters in this part
go to 1550 but this one goes to 1550 and
that but that's a challenging decision
it was a decision made I think primarily
by the primary author of this chapter
I don't recall having a general
discussion of it but when you look at
the timeline for the chapter what you
find is that by 1500 there were no
European maritime empires you would had
explorations you had had voyages but
they had not yet you know paid off in
the way they would over the next fifty
to a hundred years so that for example
the the conquest of the Aztec kingdom in
Mexico the contact the conquest of the
Incan Kingdom in Peru and the
establishment of Portuguese territories
strong points in India and Southeast
Asia and Africa these are things that
happen between 1500 and 1550 not by 1500
so that raises to me an interesting
question
to what degree do the voyages conducted
primarily by under the auspices of
Portuguese and Spanish rulers prior to
1502 what degree do they constitute a
topic in their own right and to what
degree are they the preamble to what
comes later no one in 1500 knew what was
going to come later nobody knew that
there was an Aztec empire full of silver
or an Incan Empire full of gold nobody
knew what would transpire in the anindya
notion even though the Portuguese had
reached the Indian Ocean so up to that
point
these were royal enterprises that were
seen more as the as a continuation of
things that had gone on in the 1400s and
back into the 1300s in terms of carrying
the war against the Muslims into their
home territories in southern Spain and
then beyond there into North Africa
where the Spaniards and the Portuguese
both conducted significant military
activities people at that time knew that
there was the possibility of reaching
the Indian Ocean in some manner that
would circumvent the Mediterranean trade
routes wealth came from the trade in
goods produced in Asia that had come
across the Silk Road in some cases but
more and more had come across Indian
Ocean maritime routes
reaching Europe and by the mid 1400s
being controlled by the Mameluke in the
Ottoman States and by the Italian
city-states of did business in in
ottoman and Mameluke territory under
license from those rulers so people on
the western fringe of Europe had to pay
the the increase in price of everything
they bought from Eastern Goods that came
from having these various intermediaries
so the desire to have a direct route to
the wealth of the Indies was one of the
motivations that was clearly there in
the 1400s and yet nobody knew how it was
going to pan out nobody knew how far it
would be how much it would cost how much
opposition would be met because no one
yet knew what was going to to lie across
those seas that they were very
diligently and at great cost exploring
there were two theories obviously about
how to get the Indies one was to sail
around Africa which is finally
accomplished by Vasco da Gama in the in
the 1480s and the other was to sail
across the what turned out to be the
Atlantic Ocean you know sailing westward
to Asia there was near agreement on the
impossibility of the second route
Columbus like other people that time
read accounts of of travels in Asia that
had been undertaken during the Mongol
period and more theoretical works about
the size and distances of the world and
he concluded that the distance from from
the western shores of Europe to to the
new world rather to Asia was about eight
hundred leagues the prevailing view was
that it was twenty five hundred leagues
it's a unit of distance
that's about from here to here I frankly
don't remember what a league is anyone
know how big league is twenty three
thousand but you know half a league half
a league half a league onward
can't be much farther than a mile it
must be less
person can walk in an hour
uh-huh so seven-league boots allow you
to take one step that will cover seven
hours of travel now it's very nice okay
twenty-five hundred leagues was the
common estimate and was based on the
issue of how I was a shoe if you felt
that Asia was comparatively covered a
fairly limited expense of longitude then
you assumed the water from the eastern
shores of Asia over to the western
shores of Europe if as Columbus did you
read those Travel accounts and you came
to conclusion that Asia was much much
bigger than everyone else thought then
you decided that you could get there by
sailing west Columbus's opponents were
correct
Columbus was wrong the Portuguese and
other rulers who turned him down and
said we're not going to fund an
expedition to sail off and never be seen
again they were they were smart but by
the time
Columbus presented his project to to
Queen Isabella the Portuguese had found
the way around Africa and now there was
a possibility that the Portuguese were
going to uniquely reap the advantages
because despite the fact that the
Spaniards had made some early cruises
down the Atlantic coast they had been
mostly closed out by the by the
Portuguese and the Portuguese and the
Spaniards were competing in Morocco to
see who would have more influence well
they certainly had a fleet that would
permit it because they reach the Canary
Islands and the Canary Islands the
Portuguese tried to take the Canary
Islands from the Spaniards and they
failed so the Spaniard certainly could
do deep water over the horizon sailing
my my guess is from what I understand of
it that the the Portuguese had the
accumulated reports of a long series of
ship captains which the Spaniards did
not have and what those reports would
mean were things like what are the
landmarks on shore to look for what are
the wind directions as you move into
different bands of latitude going south
in order to clear the the southern tip
of Africa how far out you have to go
into the Atlantic in order to come back
with the with the prevailing westerlies
to get around Africa I think that it was
a question of a of a proprietary body of
knowledge that the Spaniards didn't have
on the Portuguese did and the Portuguese
were shall we not going to share that
sort of thing but
from a Portuguese point of view this was
the moment that Portugal had always and
always hoped for
and it is interesting that when you look
at this at this moment
Portugal tends to together to some
degree forgotten except by the
Portuguese the the national will be
equivalent for the Portuguese of the
Dante or the Lutheran vibe or something
like that the the great monument of
Portuguese literature was called dos
Lucy Otto's the Lucy ads and written by
a poet named Louise c'mon SH I think
come on choose a correct pronunciation
of this name but if there's someone here
who's Portuguese was better than mine
home de fer come oink wrote this epic
and published it in 1576 so it is it is
about the heroism and the great
achievements of Vasco da Gama
so it's about the period primarily
before 1500 but it's written after 1500
it has it's deliberately based on the
Iliad and the and the Aeneid so that
even at the beginning the Aeneid begins
Armavir am Kwai cano meaning of arms and
the man I sing and the OSI Odyssey
begins arms and the heroes you know it's
it instead of arms and demand its arms
and heroes
arms and the heroes who from Lisbon soar
through seas where sail was never spread
before beyond where Ceylon lifts her
spicy breasts and waves her woods above
the watry waist with prowess more than
human forced their way to the fair
kingdoms of the rising day
what wars they waged what seas what
dangers past
what glorious Empire crowned their toils
at last Ventress I sing on soaring
pinions born and all my country's Wars
the song adorned what kings what heroes
of my native land thundered on asia's or
an africa
strand illustrious shades who leveled in
the dust the idol temples and the
shrines of lust and where air while foul
demons were revered to holy faith a
numbered author altars Reard
this you know it goes on for 20 more
can't see it but it is a you know it
portrays Portugal in the way that Virgil
tried to portray a world as having
achieved the most extraordinary
empire through its own resources it was
a great poem that was received with you
know with enormous acclaim when it came
out and four years later the Portuguese
kingdom came to an end because in 1580
there was a battle in Morocco and the
Portuguese King Sebastian or the
Bastille the Portuguese King was killed
it's it's the Battle of I'll give the
Arabic of it althusser al-kabir battle
of the big fortress it's you know in
Spanish and Portuguese and so forth it
has bizarre spellings that I not sure
how they pronounced it that el costo el
kebir in Arabic and it's also known as a
Battle of the three kings because you
had two contenders for the for the
Sultanate in Morocco a man and his uncle
the uncle held the position he was being
challenged by the nephew and the
Portuguese supported the nephew so King
Sebastian with his Portuguese army went
to Morocco a significant contingent of
the army was made up of English so you
had a combined Portuguese and English
and Moroccan army versus a Moroccan army
that was to some degree supported by the
Ottomans they fought a battle with none
of the three kings survived and
sebastian his remains were never found
but because of the marriage alliances
within the Portuguese ruling family
after some dispute and claims by various
other family members Portugal became
united to the crown of Spain and that
was the end of Portugal as an
independent Kingdom for a very long time
so here you had a an epic - an empire
that disappeared just now scarcely a
blink after the after the epic was
published
but it's an example of what of the
problem you get on the chronology
because that epoch could not have been
written before 1500 Kamui served in
Macao off the coast of China
he served in India he served in various
Portuguese holdings Indian Indian Ocean
what he wrote about he knew very largely
from firsthand he also had lost an eye
in battle against the Ottomans there's
an eerie parallel here because servantes
who's the parallel on the Spanish side
lost an arm and fighting against the
Ottomans so you know world literature is
greatly improved by the martial prowess
of the Ottoman army but if you if you
cut your timeline at 1500 then then it's
very awkward you know you finish your
semester you finish your course and you
haven't gotten to the Portuguese Empire
yet but you have made the crucial
discovery and this is of course a
problem that you have in in in the
degree to which you you try to
anticipate what is going to happen
because you know what's going to happen
as a story and you look back and say
well I know that what's going to happen
here is that the span of the Spaniards
are going to build an empire and the
Americas and the Portuguese is going to
build an empire in the Indian Ocean and
if I stop at 1500 those stories are just
sort of cut off on the other hand you
can do it that way in the UNESCO history
of humanity which is a seven-volume
monster work of history by 450
historians
their volume four stops in 1500 and it's
strict so when you read the section on
Europe at the very end of the section
after you've had the Crusades and this
and that the other thing expansion the
Ottoman Empire you get a fairly brief
section on Portuguese exploration you
know then you come to the end end of the
volume end of the story no mention of
what happens except that you've had
Fosco de Gama you've had Columbus and
there you are you're at the end of the
volume and it raises a question
historians always have as to whether
they should structure a narrative to to
look for the origins of things to to
sort of lay the groundwork as they often
think of it for what comes later and
that of course depends upon your
judgment of what is important about that
later
period in other words if you think that
the maritime empires based on these
discoveries are the most important story
that you're going to have for the next
few centuries then maybe it makes a lot
of sense to include them in a chapter
even if you have to ignore the
chronology on the other hand that is
something that could be
also chalked up to giving special
privileges to the narratives of European
history and say it is really a European
bias that wants the reader to end
thinking of the greatness of Europe's
achievement in the
these voyages of discovery no one for
example suggests having an ending point
at the end of the voyages of Zhang Hey
no because the Chinese story didn't go
anyplace but then if you think of it as
a European phenomenon and you think of
the longer term you say well the Germans
never had an empire but the Germans
became the makers of European history to
a substantial degree at a later point
without an empire so is it giving undue
emphasis to those European powers that
bordered the Atlantic as opposed to
other European powers and this is
something I talked about last week and
the question of do you separate Western
Europe from Central Europe and Eastern
Europe you did not need to have a
maritime Empire of globe-girdling
proportion in order to become a great
European state as the Germans showed and
as indeed as the Ottomans showed and
later on as the as a Russian show so is
this something that arises particularly
out of the particular regard that
historians of Western civilization have
for for Western Europe
maybe but there's another interpretation
available as well which is that this is
something that Americans like that this
is ultimately an American story because
you know Portugal disappears Spain goes
bankrupt but the americas go through an
extraordinary historical development
under the occupation of the Portuguese
the Spaniards the French the English
primarily and to a lesser degree others
such as the Dutch so is this something
that is essentially the history an
American historiographical equivalent of
celebrating Columbus Day
are we because you know who in Europe
would celebrate Columbus Day the Genoese
maybe because he was from Genoa but you
know are the French ready to celebrate
Columbus Day you know probably not they
sold their holdings the time of Napoleon
the Germans are going to celebrate
Columbus Day who's going to celebrate
Columbus Day except those of us who are
over here and so that gets to this
question of is world history of the sort
that is embodied in the textbooks that
we have not in the journal articles or
in the detailed studies of comparative
history or history of plagues or
frontier can compare something like that
but in the textbook a world history is
this a way in which this notion of world
history is fundamentally skewed toward
the United States is this an American
enterprise at the very beginning of the
course of the first lecture I talked
about the evolution of world history as
a topic in
and how it gradually has sort of moved
up like like a flood
you know seeping through the floorboards
and gradually pushing elite historians
up onto the roof we're finally they have
to surrender and say all right we'll
teach world history but but is this
really a distinctly American thing and
would a woody European or indeed a world
consortium of historians concur that
this narrative should be constructed to
show the the triumph of certain
Europeans now the reason I bring up the
UNESCO value because that was precisely
a project put together by a consortium
of historians from all over the world
who quite evidently felt absolutely no
no compulsion to to portray this in the
grand triumphalist fashion of either the
poetry of commence or of the Columbus
Day saga but rather simply put it in as
something that happened toward the end
of the 1400s and now we'll get along on
to the next value it isn't that special
uh
the author of the chapter that have had
this that ended at 1500 in the UNESCO
volume was not a Portuguese it's
possible that if it'd work he's author
that it would have come up somewhat
differently which just parenthetically
touches upon an issue I think he's worth
mentioning and that is if you put
together history through a consortium of
people from different backgrounds how
many different backgrounds do you have
to have in other words who speaks for
the Sumerians now who speaks for the
Acadians
who speaks now you can say okay hey the
Iraqis do and you look through Iraq for
those wonderful historians who are
masters of the history of Babylon and
well now you don't find them you do find
rebuilding a Babylon by saddam hussein
and so forth or certain glorification
because it is seen as a precursor of
modern glorious Iraq under Saddam but by
and large peoples that pass away don't
become part of the consortium I keep
that in mind when you when you think
okay the Spaniards defeat the Aztecs so
that's a saga will tell that story but
the Aztecs defeat the Toltecs and tough
for the Toltecs who really cares whom
the Aztecs beat because the only thing
ultimately it's important is that they
get beat by the Europeans you know
civilizations come civilizations go and
we end up focusing on those that have
living descendants who can talk to the
talk to the issue of their own their own
glory
well that's there doesn't need to be a
very easy way to get around it you can't
resurrect you know people or maybe you
could have a lottery where you draw a
country sort of like that Oh we'll model
um and you say let's have a model UNESCO
history and everyone will draw a country
and they will become the advocate for
that country or that tradition and
though you draw your your you know I
represent the Hopewell culture of the
Mississippi Valley during uh you know
the pre-columbian period I'll I'll fight
to get extra paragraphs for it you know
it's very difficult to imagine how how
you would how you do that on the other
hand if you have a consortium made up of
all of the current people then you have
the problem that so many of them hate
each other and want to gain advantage by
making historical claims that will be
contradicted by by the historical claims
of someone else the degree to which
petty conflicts of this sort can really
disturb history and the writing of
history is I think exemplified and this
is not immediate to this chapter
simplified by the by the history of the
Persian Gulf the Persian Gulf is called
the Persian Gulf in Iran on the Arab
side of the Gulf it's called the Arabian
Gulf the US government which buys oil
from the Arabian sides of the Gulf calls
it the Arabian Gulf
most people call a Persian Gulf
historical maps and nomenclature tend to
support the Iranian claim that it's the
Persian Gulf but it's a very
controversial issue so three four years
ago the encyclopedia or the National
Geographic magazine came out with an
atlas in which they called it no Persian
Gulf paranthesis Arabian Gulf and the
Iranian government promptly banned
National Geographic and whipped up a
internet furor about this insult to the
Iranian nation indeed an insult to
history because it had always been the
Persian Gulf
National Geographic said well we're
simply following American practice and
the Iranians had yes but that is not
history history says it is a Persian the
Persian Gulf now this might have not
have been very consequential except for
the fact that National Geographic was
sponsoring a number of archaeological
expeditions in Iran which were now being
cancelled and the prospect of not being
able to to work in Iran one of the most
rich and productive areas for historical
analogy illogical our historical
research was very disturbing to National
Geographic I only was slightly aware of
this until I got a phone call from an
archaeologist work for National
Geographic saying who can we talk to to
to normalize things I said well you can
should try it talking to the UN
ambassador for Iran they said well will
you come with us so I had had the fun of
going downtown and first having a
strategy lunch with the National
Geographic people and the head of the
National Geographic said well we're
simply going to hold the line you know
we will call it Arabian Gulf and Persian
Gulf equally and that is that's that I
said well okay that that's the end of
that because you'll get nowhere this is
a non-starter what you need to do is to
have to label it Persian Gulf with an
asterisk and then or a note and then in
the note you can say this is known by
certain states as the Arabian Gulf so we
went into the meeting with the
Ambassador very pleasant man but he was
ferocious on this matter and national
graphic Geographic said well here is our
position and he said yeah well that's
not an acceptable position that's um you
know not going to work he said but we're
following you know u.s. Board of
Geographic Names and so for I said yes
but you know from our point of view you
are the gold standard in geography
everyone follows you and do you want to
be known as an organization that follows
the political whims of the US government
because we respect you so much and
indeed my children love National
Geographic it is heartbreaking that the
Iranian children not get to see National
Geographic because you are cow towing to
to these shapes in the Gulf who have you
know blackmailed the US government into
using Arabian Gulf so then
we actually graphic guy said well what
about a footnote and ambassador perked
up said yeah
that's a possibility amended of it the
debate got into the question of would it
have to be on the same page good could
it be a footnote to somewhere unlocated
in the atlas so that the the note would
be there but nobody would ever find and
by the time we left there was a a
agreement in principle that a footnote
would take care of the problem and
ultimately the issue was was resolved
but this question of who whose history
is it becomes extremely vexed as soon as
you get into the notion that history
should if it's going to be global or
world or something like that that it
should somehow reflect the interests of
of parties
the area where this becomes perhaps the
most next for the period of this chapter
has to do as I talked about last time
with the question of the Ottoman Empire
for from the standpoint of most
Europeans including the Spaniards and to
a substantial degree including the
Portuguese the biggest threat was from
the Ottoman Empire this time the in 1492
the last Muslim Kingdom in Spain and the
Iberian Peninsula had been conquered at
Granada and the kingdom of Castile had
taken over so the Ottomans were not a
immediate presence in the Iberian
Peninsula but the Ottomans were very
aggressive at that time pushing into
North Africa and in pressing for Ottoman
power in the western Mediterranean Sea
this this remains a poorly studied area
though there is a excellent book by
Andrew Hess called The Forgotten
frontier that gives a quite a detailed
history of the dealings between the
Algerians the Moroccans the Ottomans the
French the Spaniards and the Portuguese
in this time period of the 15th and 16th
centuries showing that the the great
preoccupation was would the Ottomans
extend their power into the western
Mediterranean and in the 16th century
you get a point where the
we're the king of Spain who was also
holier Holy Roman Emperor Charles a
fifth is fighting against the Ottomans
and the King of France Francis the first
is an ally of the Ottomans and you
actually have the Ottoman fleet spending
the winter in southern France allied to
protected by the French King you might
think why would a Christian King
particularly one who has the title the
most Christian King be protecting the
Ottoman fleet
what would he look at English history
you find that for a couple of hundred
years the English and the Moroccans had
very close relations they had
essentially an alliance and you had
important exchanges of trade and so
forth between England and Morocco it is
I think generally thought that or not
not generally thought it is suspected
that Othello the more Venice is give
sort of a nod to the Moroccan
relationship in Shakespeare's work you
also had as I've already mentioned a
close relationship between certain
Moroccan political interests and and the
Portuguese Portugal at that time was
receiving most of its are much of its
wheat supply for Morocco because
Portugal does not have a large
agricultural enterprise for growing
staple grains so the the image of of a
Christian a Christian world versus of
Muslim world which
grew out of Crusades and which continues
to be enshrined in history books really
did not reflect the reality you had a
much more complex set of relationships
in which religion was not was often not
the most important consideration
so the Ottomans played a played a
crucial role recently there has been a
book published by Giancarlo Kasauli
professor Minnesota that is on the
Ottoman strategy in the Indian Ocean and
what the Ottomans did visa vie the
Portuguese and it is it's quite
extraordinary because historians up
until Casal eyes work have assumed that
the ottomans ignored the Indian Ocean or
had a very minor concern when Casali
argues is that the Ottomans were just as
concerned about trade and military power
in the Indian Ocean as a Portuguese word
that the investment of the Ottomans in
naval resources was equivalent to the
investment of the Portuguese and naval
resources and that in fact the ottomans
were were a worthy adversary to the
portuguese and indeed for a long time
until the ottoman interior politics
shifted away from that strategy the
ottomans were more than holding their
own in the indian ocean area so if if in
future
additions of the earth and its peoples
or perhaps other world history textbooks
people start to take into account the
work of Kasauli then they're going to
have a very hard time talking about the
Portuguese without talking about the
Ottomans so you can say well global
maritime expansion Indian Ocean sub
section deals with Portugal now in the
future going to have to say it deals
with Portugal and the Ottoman Empire and
if you do that then you have to talk
about the Ottoman Empire in the
Mediterranean and then you're revising
the entire the entire chapter because
you you can't separate the maritime
efforts of the Ottomans and the in the
ocean from the maritime efforts of the
Ottomans in the Mediterranean there is a
technological side to this that tends to
get lost
because we look traditionally at what
happens in the Atlantic as being
separate for what happens in the
Mediterranean there's a one of the best
books of military technology by a man
named John Gil Martin uh it's called
gunpowder and galleys and it deals with
the evolution of maritime warfare in
this time period and it's it's a
strikingly interesting analysis every
part of it has not been agreed to by
other historians but by and large it's
it's held up I think quite well he
starts out by saying that in the early
20th century
there was a famous writer Admiral mayim
who wrote a theoretical book on seapower
he said that what happens in C power
when you look historically is that you
have a fight between two navies you have
a engagement the two navies meet one
Navy wins the other Navy loses and then
the winning Navy is able to blockade the
seaport of the losing Navy and buy a
blockade it means that they can sail
back and forth outside the harbor and
prevent any imports and any exports and
that by crippling the import and export
trade of a country they can bring that
country to its knees and this of course
was something that was best exemplified
during the Napoleonic Wars in the 19th
century when the when the British were
able to blockade French ports so
Gilmartin said that is a you know a
sound theory for a certain period of
time but it doesn't go back very far now
the reason it doesn't go back very far
was that you had a change in in military
technology the assumption that maen
made was that you would have a fleet
engaging one fleet against another that
would be followed up by a blockade but
these sorts of fleet engagements were
not actually very common in early times
at least not in the way that may have
visualized them instead what you had
were galleys and galley warfare that is
say Road warships was a particular
feature of the Mediterranean but not
exclusively the Mediterranean in other
words the Vikings used
warships as well but it was the
Mediterranean going back to Greek and
Roman times where you had a long banks
of rowers propelling the the warship
through the sea and Gilmartin said how
did warfare take place with a gallon he
said that the the really limiting factor
in galley warfare was fresh water here
you had a narrow sleek war vessel that
you might put under sail if you were in
peaceful conditions but when you got
into a battle everyone put their oars in
the water and you and you maneuvered
with the oars which mean you had a large
number of people doing the rowing the
people doing the rowing are exerting a
lot of energy and they have to drink a
lot of water and there is a limit water
is very heavy there's a limit to how
much water you can carry so the problem
is that a galley cannot remain at sea
for a very long period of time because
it has to really go to port virtually
every night in order to replenish so
that the idea of a blockade where you
would have a vessel that would sail back
and forth in front of a harbor you
couldn't do it with the galley so what
you would have instead let's say you
have a harbor here you know towns down
here and ships will come out of this
Harbor you know carrying goods and
receiving Goods coming in so what you
want to do if you're the enemy is build
a fortress capture some land and build a
fortress at the mouth of the harbor and
then have your galleys pull up on the
shore close enough to the entrance of
the harbor so that if they see a ship
approaching either to leave or to enter
they can you know get in the boat
you know and start rowing after it and
and attack the vessel so this put a
great deal of emphasis upon strong
points on the shore in the anime
envision a strong point in the shore
doesn't make it doesn't it's not
necessary you have your ships at sea and
they can sail back and forth because the
number of men in a in a modern European
sailing vessels a modern the 17th 18th
century terms the number of men on board
wasn't all that great and the size of
the ship was great enough to carry
plenty of fresh water so you could stay
at sea for for weeks on end but in the
earlier time back the period in this
chapter is set you you have these strong
points on shore now the reason this
worked was that cannon were developed
and cannon in particular were set in
these fortresses so that
you would land your galleys here on the
beach and just pull the rowboats up on
the beach and if anyone came and tried
to attack your galleys you would have
cannon and the fortress that would shoot
at them from a distance and keep them
off so cannon develop as fairly
substantial pieces of ordnance that are
placed in fortresses on shore they may
be placed by this fortress may
originally then built by the people who
hold seaport and the cannon may have
been placed by them but the main thing
is that you have heavy cannon that are
guarding the port or in strong points
that if they are captured by the enemy
can be used to to close the shipping in
the port so cannon become a very
important development but cannon that
are put in a in a fortress on shore are
very heavy they're big they shoot shoot
cannonballs fairly long distances and
you can't easily put them in a galley
because the the heavier the weapon you
put in the galley the harder you have to
row and in order to fight at sea in a
galley the typical way you did it was
that you're rowing along and you're
Captain Trice maneuver so that you are
heading toward an enemy vessel in such a
way that you're going to hit it
broadside that's a your your beak is
going to hit its side and you have a
protruding you know ram essentially at
the front of your galley you're going to
ram the other galley and then when you
ram you're going to run forward and leap
across I just saw pirates of the
Caribbean
over the weekend on television so that's
very exciting for me you're going to run
forward and leap across sort of Jack
Sparrow like and kill all of the enemies
on the other side and there were huge
engagements where this would happen
where you just have thousands of men
rolling like mad trying to hit the other
galley just right and and bring out a
victory
now rowing like mad Jon Gilmartin
quantified that he said how fast is that
because he said you know you have to go
at a certain speed in order to really
hit the other galley
with enough force to you know to damage
it so that you can board and therefore
you have to you may row at so many
strokes per minute under ordinary
conditions but then under ramming
conditions you row much much harder and
you you do a you know a power 20 or a
power 25 something like that and you
close the distance as rapidly as you can
with as much force as you can of course
you have to have a more fresh water
because everyone's getting exhausted
rowing at that speed so then he said
well would it be better to simply put a
cannon on the boat and shoot at the
enemy from a distance and then row up
and hit the enemy because you've you've
kept his head down you scared him maybe
you've even hit the other one with your
cannon so then he he look to the
question of if you fired it if you put a
cannon on a galley and you fired it how
long did it take you to reload it
because loading a cannon from the front
was a cumbersome point of do you had to
swap out the residue you had to put in
the powder you had to put in the ball
you had to put in something to keep the
ball from from bouncing out
ah and he said you know if you are
rowing at top speed
if you fire from a distance and then you
row you're going to hit the other boat
before you can reload because you can't
go that far at that speed so he said the
logic was that you put cannon on the
boat to fire them the moment you hit so
you at the front of the galley you you
put up kind of a TV antenna that has
cannons on it now shooting out in them
different shooting forward because of an
array of cannons but they're all small
like an inch or two in diameter for the
bore and then as you you know you you
charge you roll like mad and then just
as you're hitting the other boat you
touch off all of the cannon on your on
your front array to to blow away the
enemy right at the point of contact then
you go and you leap across and you
occupy the other the other side so he
quantified this and experimented very
convincingly and he said that the the
upshot is that if you were fighting in
the Mediterranean it made no difference
whether you were an Italian or an
ottoman or North African or a French
whoever you were you were in the same
sort of technological situation there
was no advantage to having a big cannon
on a galley there's a huge advantage to
have big cannon in the in the fortresses
on shore and big cannon you can still go
and and see the big cannons that people
put in Shore points there are big
castles in Oman for example at the
entrance of the harbor that will have
huge Portuguese
going back to this era but to have a a
cannon in the boat the cannons were so
heavy if they were big plus the fact
that you couldn't reload it fast enough
to use it tactically in the factored
manner so we what he argued was that you
did not have gunpowder warfare at a high
level in the Mediterranean Sea because
you had technological limitations that
made put the premium on fast growing
rather than on superior cannon you might
note that right down to the to the 19th
century when you get the United States
gets into the Barbary wars against the
Libyans and Asians the North Africans
are using galleys galley slaves are also
being used by Christian powers so the
galley is so efficient for Mediterranean
purposes even as cannon change in
character that the galley is still the
dominant war vessel down in the early
19th century so this is not a trivial
matter but what he argues is that if you
were in the Atlantic they didn't use
galleys the waves were higher the winds
were stronger it was a it was a harder
sea to sail in and so you had to have
higher sides and you had to build up the
ship and have it be haul rather than
long and sleek you might still have oars
as I say the Vikings had oars and they
had long sleek ships but you know they
barely light cold water but but the the
Spanish and the Portuguese and then
later the English and French develop
ships that have high sides
small numbers of crew and big guns
because once you have the bigger ship or
the taller ship in particular then you
could put cannon in the ship and you
didn't do ramming what you were
interested in now was firing your cannon
from a distance Gilmartin argues that it
was almost impossible for one atlantic
ship to hit another you know in the in
the 1400 1500 s into the 1600s that you
know you have a cannon it's singing a
long time a load it and then but you're
in a boat that's tipping you know
there's the Windsors you know and so
forth it was very hard to to hit the I
did young he gives the example need the
American Revolutionary War of the
Serapis and the bon home Richard who are
fighting against each other side by side
all day long and neither one is able to
sink the other because it's just very
hard to to actually use your can and
effectively on the other hand it's for
bomb Marting ashore target it's more
effective the galleys after all have to
land here on the shore and move into
town on foot whereas with a one of these
Atlantic vessels you can commune bombard
a city from offshore and it doesn't make
any difference whether you've hit the
building you're aiming at or whether you
get a different building a million
enough buildings you're going to have
something and that will be will achieve
your game so Gilbert argued that even
though the vision that Admiral maen had
of a of a blockade regime following a
fleet engagement was not historically
valid nevertheless there was over time a
steadily increasing value
to the heavy guns of the of the vessels
that were being built on the western
shores of the of the European continent
and that the Spanish and the Portuguese
and the French and the English did
ultimately come up with a more effective
fighting vessel but it was a slow
process it was not fast
you had hybrids between the
Mediterranean and the Atlantic it was a
complex technological development and
one in which the Assumption that's often
made that European vessels once they got
into the Indian Ocean or into the South
China Sea were always superior to local
vessels that wasn't true they had
different tactics and they would
frequently fight in kind of sort of
mongrel fashion neither one
neither side fighting in its according
to his preferred tactic but the European
vessels were not automatically superior
and also the notion that the European
vessels were European as opposed to
being Atlantic because some of those
powerful European nations particularly
France and the Italians we're still
using galleys in the Mediterranean so if
you're going to talk about global
maritime expansion which is the topic of
this chapter it seems to me that it's
it's difficult to do if you don't
include the Mediterranean and if you
don't deal with the technological
aspects of the difference and the of
between different types of naval warfare
and the evolution of
and it's difficult to do without
involving yourself in the politics of
the Ottoman Empire
and the politics of Christians versus
Muslims in this time if you do it the
way we have done it in the earth and its
people's you give the impression that
Europe is at the beginning of a great
rise that Europe is going to become the
master of the world which it does not
quarreling with that but the question is
whether historically there is a stronger
rationale behind the idea that you give
a more or less multifaceted account of
Seabourn politics and warfare at that
time including galley warfare and
Mediterranean politics as well as the
those things in the Indian Ocean and the
Atlantic you have more rationale for
that then you have for for simply
talking about the great conquests of the
Europeans in Mexico and Peru and the
establishment of Portuguese Empire where
you seem to have more of an objective of
laying the groundwork the groundwork for
a later European hegemony than actually
reflecting the complexity of the
politics and of the economic relations
of that time so once again I'm finding
fault with the authors of the earth and
his peoples probably I should have
picked a different textbook
to use one that would work better but
that is all I have to say about this
chapter and then on Thursday I'm going
to talk about the rest of the course
and where things might go and where they
should go